لقد وصفت السرية بأنها لحظة حاسمة
بالنسبة للشركة حيث كان الكثير من
الناس يقولون "انظر ، هل هذا سوف
يكسرك الآن أنت تتحدث عنه
فيما يتعلق بإعلانات
اليوم نوعًا من إثبات العمل في المستقبل
لما
تقوله شركة airbnb  هي ثورة
سفر بمعنى ما وقد قمنا بتغيير
الطريقة التي نختار السفر بها طوال
الوقت
الذي نسافر فيه وكيف نبقى
نتحدث فقط عن التغييرات التي
أجريتها وكيف يرتبط ذلك
بسلوكياتنا المتغيرة  بقدر ما يتعلق الأمر بالسفر
بشكل
صحيح ، على الرغم من
عودة السفر للخارج وعبر الحدود ،
نعتقد أن السفر قد تغير إلى الأبد
وهذا لأن الناس يمكنهم حقًا العمل
والعيش من أي مكان الآن بفضل
التكبير وفصلهم عن
المكتب الذي تعرف أننا  لقد استطلعت آراء
الموظفين
و 68 منهم يتوقعون المزيد من
المرونة في المستقبل أه مع
إعداد عملهم حتى تعرف أننا
نفكر في هذا ما
تعلمناه وشهدناه خلال هذه الفترة من
السلطة الفلسطينية  ndemic uh سوف يكون
متاحًا للكثيرين في المستقبل
وهذا سيسمح للناس بالسفر بشكل أكثر مرونة
كما تعلم أننا نرى الكثير من
الاهتمام بالسفر أه في منتصف الأسبوع كانت أيام الاثنين
والثلاثاء أسرع
أيام
السفر بالنسبة إلى أه سنوات  في الماضي كما
تعلم ، نرى 53 شخصًا يقولون إنك
تعلم أنهم يفكرون في السفر خارج أوقات الذروة
الآن ،
لذا فهي تتيح
لك ليس فقط اصطحابك لمعرفة الرحلات الكبيرة
مرة واحدة في السنة ،
ولكن أيضًا لأخذ الكثير من
الإقامات العفوية القريبة
وحتى العمل أثناء اه.  نقوم
بهذا العمل من منزل آخر ومع
الإعلانات التي تم الإعلان عنها يوم أمس أننا جعلنا
الميزات الجديدة واحدة منها تم
التحقق منها عبر شبكة wi-fi ، لذلك لاحظنا هذا العام
أن 288 مليون شخص استخدموا
عامل تصفية wi-fi الذي يريدون العثور
عليه  موطن شبكة wifi ولكن بالطبع معظم المنازل
بها شبكة wi-fi هذه الأيام ، ما
يسألون عنه حقًا هو مدى سرعة اتصال wi-
fi الآن ، سنحصل على
السرعة المعتمدة والتصنيف في كل
قائمة حتى تتمكن من الحصول على
الثقة  في المنزل الذي تحجزه سيدعم
أسلوب حياتك في العمل الرقمي